- [Mark] All right, Leslie.
Leslie, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- Baltimore, Maryland, Charm City.
- [Mark] Okay (chuckles).
Tell me about your family.
Had both your parents growing up?
- No, I never met my father until later on
but in fact about six years
ago, I actually met him.
But my mom's was my primary caretaker.
I have two younger brothers
one of them now deceased
the youngest brother.
My brother Craig is a, he retired
he was a correctional
officer for the Department
of Public Safety and Correctional
Services in Baltimore.
- [Mark] And tell me about your childhood.
You had a good childhood?
- Yeah, I had a pretty good childhood.
I mean, I spent a lot of my
time traveling back and forth.
I actually was raised by my
godmother in Brooklyn, New York.
I would be sent back to my
mom's house to spend time
in the summer there in Baltimore.
- [Mark] Why were you not
with your mom full time?
Why were you not with your mom full time?
- To be honest with you.
I really believe it was
because of her animosity
and sincere attitude with
my father whom I never met.
I bear the burden of
being his child, okay.
- [Mark] And then tell me,
what kind of kid were you in high school?
- In high school I was pretty good.
As far as the student,
I was real good with working stuff out.
I did my work and got good grades and all,
but I actually started to excel
in playing basketball in school.
From junior high school up to high school
I actually played on
the junior varsity team
and then the varsity team
at Southern High School
in Baltimore, Maryland
when I was there.
Prior to that I played
in the neighborhood,
they had a league that they
started, they call BNBL
which is the Baltimore
Neighborhood Basketball League,
where the communities will play
against each other in the city.
And then at the end, they will have
a citywide championship
that will actually play
at the place called the
Baltimore Civic Center
which is now called the Baltimore Arena.
I was able to hone my skills
and become more experienced
in playing ball and was getting write-ups
in the News-American newspaper,
the Baltimore Sun paper,
in regardless to being player of the week.
I actually started getting recognition
for my ability to play
basketball at school.
My coaches and them were
actually treating me
to the point where, "Look
Leslie you have the ability
"and people are starting
to recognize this,
"and it's a possibility
you might go forward
"if you consider playing
ball in college and all."
Which I did.
- [Mark] Were you getting a scholarship?
- Yeah, I was looking for scholarships,
North Carolina State, USC,
Maryland naturally,
University of Maryland,
Lefty Driesell down there in Maryland.
I met with him and talked to him before,
actually before I was
wrongfully convicted and all
in regards to actually
considering plan at Maryland.
I had opportunities to meet
with coaches and so forth
in New York when I was
living in New York also
in regards to playing ball.
I've also played in the
Rutgers League up there too
over at Manhattan, up in Harlem.
- [Mark] And your high school team was?
- My high school team
was extremely strong.
We actually went forth
and played against Dunbar
which was a leading high school
in the State of Maryland.
They had Skip Wise, they had Larry Gibson
who played center for Dunbar.
Dunbar's coach was a well-known coach
throughout the Scholastic
Basketball League.
His name was Sugar Cain.
These are the individuals
that I played basketball with
during the time that I was,
well, before I was wrongfully convicted.
These were the people who
actually were ball players
in that era of time that I played at.
- [Mark] And then tell me what happened
to you at 17 years old?
You're still a high school kid, right?
- Yeah I was still a high school kid.
I worked in the, what
they call Muhly's Bakery,
which was a bakery that had
been in business for many years.
It was located near a Cross Street Market,
and anyone who is familiar with Maryland
is familiar with the
Inner Harbor, Fells Point,
those areas are areas of
prominence where people resided at.
Well, this bakery that
I worked at was situated
in that community.
In the evening after I
had basketball practice
I would go to work at the
bakery, would stay there
and work until later in the evening,
and then leave and go to
my grandfather's house
who lived at one Hanover Street,
which was a couple of blocks
from the market and all.
Just by coincidence I
was at home with my mom,
this one day, I think it was a Saturday,
and she asked me to go to the
store and get a newspaper,
something that I been doing for years,
you know, it was a normal thing.
So I went to, walked over to a drug store,
it's called a Westport
Pharmacy on Annapolis Road,
which was the only neighborhood
store in the community.
And I went in, I spoke
to doc who was the owner
of the store.
I spoke with, Clarence McCleary,
we call Old Man Clarence,
and Mr. Willie Adams,
Willie, Old Man Willie.
They were full-time delivery drivers
for the Westport Pharmacy
that was in the neighborhood
that I lived in.
I spoke with them and
then I went up front,
I made the purchase and
I came out of the store.
- [Mark] Just a newspaper?
- Yeah, the newspaper that's
all she wanted was the news
'cause she read the paper and stuff--
- [Mark] And you're basically
just a kid whose life--
- I was a kid.
I was a kid.
- [Mark] Your life revolved
around basketball and school.
- My life was about basketball.
I didn't have no girlfriends.
I wasn't interested in no girlfriend.
The only girlfriend I
had was that basketball,
- [Mark] No gangs, nothing like that?
- No gangs and all that
stuff during that time,
if it was it wasn't in the
community that I lived in.
It was none of that.
It was none of the things that you see
now that's transpired.
It was a wholesome environment,
kids used to go out in the
street and play marbles
and skillet and red hot butter beans
and all those kinda games and stuff.
Kids were kids or adults were adults.
Kids knew what they suppose,
was required of them.
When the lights, when it
started getting dark outside
and the street lights start coming on,
you know to be home, you
know those kinds of things.
And I came out the drug store.
I remember standing there
waiting to cross the street
coming back towards my home.
And I heard this man say,
"You with the leather coat on
"go put your hands against the wall."
I don't know, I heard it,
but I wasn't really paying
on mind, because I knew
they couldn't have been talking to me.
I didn't know was going on.
So I looked and it was an
officer, a police officer
with this revolver pulled
out and he was pointing it.
And he said, "You get up against the wall
"put your hands against the wall."
And I looking, I'm looking, 'cause I know,
but I'm assuming he's not talking to me
'cause I ain't done nothing.
I don't know what's going on.
I pointed myself, and he said,
"Yeah, you with the beige leather coat,
put your hands against the wall.
I said, "What'd I do?
He said, "Get up against the wall."
And I walked over, put my
hands against the wall,
and he came up behind me and he said,
"Put your face against the wall,"
and put the gun to the back of my head.
And he said, "You robbed a drug store."
I said, "No, I didn't, I just
come out to the drugstore.
I said, "Doc can tell you,
I didn't rob no drugstore,
"he know me, he know who I am."
And the guy was, the officer was like,
"I don't care, I don't
wanna hear none of that."
Then I heard him say, "Is this the guy?"
And the man, I heard a voice,
only thing, because of him
having a gun against my head,
my face against the wall, I
was afraid to turn my head
'cause I didn't want this man to shoot me.
The week to prior to this
there was an incident that
was, that had been documented,
and they was talking about
and people were protesting
because a officer was supposedly
shot at another teenager
in Baltimore in some other community.
And he said, "You're under
arrest for robbing a drug store.
"the police wagon's coming to get you."
And I'm like, "Well, I didn't do nothing."
So I said, "Ask doc,
I didn't do anything."
And he said, "I don't wanna hear it."
He said, "You've got to tell
it to the judge and all that."
All the while I'm saying to myself,
"God what is going on?
"I came here to get a newspaper now what?"
So it was other people standing out there
that lived in that community,
and the people was like,
"Leslie, what's going on?
"Why them police messing
with you and all that?"
I said, "He said, I
robbed the drug store."
He said, "Rob the drug store?"
These are people in the
community standing around
because across the street
from this drugstore
was homes, was houses.
And these people knew
me from the neighborhood
and they was like,
"Well, what's going on?"
They tried to talk to the police,
trying to tell him,
"This kid lives out here.
"They know him.
"All you've got to do is ask
the owner he's in the store.
"He didn't do this.
"What are you talking about?"
So he was like, he was
adamant that he wasn't trying
to do anything but arrest
me that particular day.
And I really, even as I think back now
and I sit and I remember
how that whole scenario
played out, and the
fact that I didn't know,
I had no idea what was going on.
And then him not wanting to take me
into the store for the owner
of the store to verify
that I was not the person,
this only inflamed things more.
So a fellow that was standing
there named Harrison Conyers,
I never forget Harrison and
I grew up on Kent Street,
that's where I lived at on Kent Street
in the Westford project.
He said, "Leslie, I'm gonna tell your mom
"I'm go tell Ms. Clara,
the police arrested you."
My mother's name was Clara.
So he said, "I'm gonna go tell Miss Clara
"that they arrested you and so forth."
And I'm like, "Okay."
But all the while I'm scared to death
because I don't know what is going on.
This is not something that,
this is not a everyday thing for me.
I'd never been stopped by the police,
I had never been accosted in any kind,
I never had any kind of
interaction with the police.
And to be honest with you, I was a child,
I was 17 years of age, but
I was a child in mentality.
I had no understanding
of what was transpiring.
I had no knowledge of what
was going to procedures
that was happening.
The only thing I know is
that I'm standing here,
this man with has gun against my head,
and if I move he can kill me.
That's all I could think of.
When the police wagon came and
he put me in a police wagon,
they carted me to the station.
I remember when I got there
and they took me out the wagon,
and officers said, "What's your name?"
And I said, "Leslie Vass."
And he said, "How old are you?"
I said, "17."
He says, "17!"
He said, "Sarge, we got a juvenile here."
He has to be sequestered
from everybody else.
Meaning they couldn't put
me with other individuals.
So he put me in a, they
walked me back and put me
in this area where it was just the cells,
and I was, he put me in the first cell
and he put a tag on there
saying that I was a juvenile.
And the guard, I remember, the officers,
when they called Sarge, he said,
"Wow, he a big kid for a 17-year old, boy"
I stood six, four at that time,
but still I just, you know,
as I try to
go back over everything that happened,
I just feel like, you
know, it's truly traumatic
because I didn't understand
what was going on.
I had no idea that I
was being charged as a,
I was a juvenile, but I was
being charged as an adult.
Then later on, they came and got me,
and told me that I had to
see a court commissioner,
which they call the initial appearance.
And when I went before this man
they cuffed me in the courtroom,
I saw my mother.
And when I went into the
courtroom, I could see her.
I saw her friend, Mr.
Johnny sitting with her
and my neighbor, Miss Mick
which was a friend like
an aunt to me right.
They was telling me just to hold on
that it'll be alright and stuff.
And then the judge said,
"Well, we will release you
"into the custody of your mother
because you're a juvenile,
"you don't have a prior arrest record."
He said, I remember him
saying, "But I'm telling you
"if you go over to the pharmacy
"or you talk to anybody
that work at this pharmacy,
"and it comes back to the
courts, that's a violation
"and you will be rearrested
and held without bail."
All these things is foreign to me
'cause I don't understand, what is a bail?
I don't have no idea about
none of these things.
They released me.
And as we was walking to the car,
I was trying to tell my mom, I said,
"Look," I said, "I don't know
"what these people talking about."
And she said, "Don't worry about it.
"I'ma get a lawyer for you.
"You do what the lawyer tell you to do.
"That's all I want you to do.
"Don't go over there near
that drugstore, Leslie.
"And don't talk to Mr.
Clarence, and don't talk
"to none of these other
people that work there
"because they gonna lock
you back up if you do."
That's all I could, that's
all I remember, lock up.
If I talk to anybody, if I go
over there to that drug store.
Those were the things
that stuck in my mind.
First of all, I was at a cell by myself,
that I could put my, spread my arms out
and put my hands on each side
of the balls, where I was at
with the little toilet and
the thing and a sink, right.
And I ain't trying to be there,
that's not where I wanna be.
She paid this attorney.
She was referred to this attorney
by the name of Robert Paul Conrad.
And when we first met him,
she made it specifically clear to me.
"You do what this lawyer tell you to do.
"I don't care what.
"I'm paying him, he's the lawyer.
"He knows about the law.
"You don't know anything about it.
"And you do what he say to do."
I'm a kid, I do what
my mom tells me to do.
The first time that I met him without her,
the first thing he said to me was,
"Did your mother send me
a check or an envelope?"
So I said, "Yeah, she gave me
an envelope to give to you."
I give him the envelope.
And he started saying to me,
"Well we're gonna have a hearing
"and when we go have the hearing
"I want you to listen to
everything that I tell you.'
And I'm saying, "Okay."
I said, "But sir," I said
"They said that I've robbed a drug store.
"I know the guy that owned the drug store.
"I know Mr. Clarence, I
know Mr. Willie Adams,
"Old Man Willie.
"I know Old Man Willie, I know Clarence."
I said, "I know some of the other workers
"that work in the store."
I said, "Man, these people can tell you
"I didn't rob that place."
And he just looking at me, he said,
"Don't worry about that."
He said, "We will take care of this.
"It's not gonna be a problem, okay."
So I said, "All right."
I went about doing what I was doing,
I was still going to school.
I remember one time
I got a paper that said I
supposedly went to court,
but when my mom called
to talk to the lawyer
he said, "Don't worry about it
"the case is gonna be dismissed."
"It's gonna be postponed.
"And when I ask you to go to court
"it's gonna be going for trial."
I don't know anything other
than what's been said to me,
that I'm charged with
robbing a store, right.
I was arrested February 15th, 1975
on Annapolis Road, after
walking out of the drugstore.
July 2nd, 1975 I appeared
at the then Supreme Bench
for Baltimore City at
111 North Calvert Street
in Baltimore City for court.
When I got there, the
doors to the courtroom
were actually locked, and people
were just standing around outside
waiting for the courtroom
doors to be opened.
So as I was standing
there, I see Mr. Clarence
I see Old Man Willie Adams,
and I see this other dude,
and they're all standing
around this white guy
with a yellow manila folder.
And they talk and the Mr. Clarence look up
and he see me standing over
there and he said to me
"Leslie what are you doing out here?"
My immediate thought was,
"These people will lock you up
"if you talk to this man, you understand?"
That's my first and foremost thought,
so I don't want to say nothing to him.
So he's like, "What's wrong with you?"
I bust out crying,
and I say to him, I said,
"They gonna lock me up
"if I talk to you."
He said, "What are you
talking about Leslie?"
I said, "They charged me
with robbing a drug store."
He said to me, he said, "Wait a minute.
"What, when did that happen?"
I said, "February and when
I came in to drugstore
"to buy my mama paper,
as I leave out of there,
"they arrest me and said,
I robbed a drug store."
He said, "They lock you up for that?"
I see "Yeah."
So Mr. Willie is standing
there and he says,
"Man what the hell is going,
excuse me, he said, "What
the hell is going on here?"
And they looking at each other,
like it's something, they
know that I'm not familiar.
I don't know anything about.
So he said, "Leslie,
come on and go with me,
"walk over here."
So he walks me over to the white guy
with the yellow folder and
he says to him, he said
"Y'all lock this kid up,
this is who y'all locked up?"
He said, "We know this
child, this kid come from
"out of Westport community.
"This kid wasn't involved
in this robbery."
He said, "Something is wrong."
He said, "This is not the kid."
He said, "The people that robbed
our co-worker were older."
He said, "We know this kid, this kid
"has been coming to the store
"since he was a small little boy."
He said, "You got the wrong
person, not this boy."
So the guy, I remember the
guy saying to him, he said,
"Well, guess what we
don't need your testimony.
"We're not gonna use
y'all, you dismissed."
And Mr. Willie said, "You know what,
"these people gonna do
some real fucked up shit."
That's what he said.
And I mean that's exactly
how he said it right there
in the hallway, outside of the courtroom.
Then they opened the doors
to the courtroom and
everybody started going in.
So as I'm going in, Mr. Willie said,
"Where's your lawyer,
Leslie, who is your lawyer?"
So I said, "I don't see him right now."
I said, "Oh, there he go."
He had just came up the steps.
I said, "He already talked to
that man you always talk to."
And they look at each other
and then they looked back at me
and they said, "Leslie, you
know, where's your mom."
'Cause they knew that my
mother was a single mother.
These people at this time
were delivery drivers
who came into the community to deliver
food, medication, alcohol
so there was a bar in
the back of this place,
and so they were friendly
with all the people
in the community, you know.
I'm standing there
and apparently that
man had told Mr. Conrad
that I was talking to the two witnesses
and they had said
something to him about it.
And he came, when he
approached me, he approached me
like, "Didn't I tell you not
to talk to nobody about that?'
I don't care who they are.
I said, "Well, they told
him that I didn't do this."
He said, "I don't care what they said.
"I told you, your mother told you to do
"what I tell you to do.
"That's what you're supposed to do.
"Don't talk to nobody.
"Go there, have a seat."
And I'm saying, I'm trying
to figure out why he upset
with me and mad with me because
I talked to these people?
And these people apparently know something
about what was going on.
Now, when they, I'm
sitting in the I'm sitting
in the courtroom,
I remember I heard a movement behind me
but my mind is so messed
up about being here
I don't understand what's going on.
And then I'm thinking, you know,
"Why is this lawyer, my
lawyer mad at me for talking
"with these people who
work in the drugstore?"
I said, when he come over, I said,
"Mr. Conrad" I said,
"they saying something
"about somebody that was a delivery driver
"that was robbed now."
I said, "But they charged me
with robbing the drug store.
They didn't send nothing
about no delivery driver.
So he said, "You don't know,
"you never see a person
that pick you out."
I said, "Nobody picked me out.
"Pick me out for what?"
He said, "Leslie, the day
that you was arrested.
"Did anybody say that you robbed them?"
And I said, "No, not that I remember."
I said, "The only thing I remember
"was that the officer
had the gun to my head,"
and I said, "Oh, I
remember hearing a voice,
"the officer saying to
somebody, 'Is this the man?'
"And he said, 'Yeah, it looks like him,'
"and then that was it.
"But there's nothing else said, right."
So I said, "I don't know."
I said, "What did that suppose mean?"
He said, "Well, so you don't
know that the robbery happened
"in November of 1974 in Cherry Hill."
So I said, "Cherry Hill,
what are you talking about?
"I was arrested on Annapolis Road
"right in front of the Westport Pharmacy."
"Maybe they got me."
He said, "No Leslie the
original crime happened,
"November 2nd, 1974, a
part-time delivery driver
"for the Westport Pharmacy
was making a delivery."
So I said, "I don't know
anything about none of this."
I said, "This is the first
time I'm hearing it."
I said, "You telling me
something I have no idea about."
So I said, "If it was on
a weekend or something
"usually I'm on at my grandfather's house
"because on Fridays, we
had basketball practice,
"I leave there and go to
work at Muhly's Bakery,
"my grandfather lived
right around the corner
"on Hanover Street, and
I used to go there.'
"And after work at the bakery
"because it was late in the evening
"and didn't no public transportation run
"after a certain period of
time where we lived at."
So he said, "Well, don't worry about it."
So I said, "Well who was this
part-time delivery driver?"
I said, "Because Mr. Clarence I'd know,
"Willie Adams I'd know, you understand.
"I don't know of no other
delivery drivers that work
"for the Westport Pharmacy.
"I've never known of any."
So he said, "Well, this man only worked
"one day a week on a Saturday,
"and he originally worked for
the gas and electric company,
"but he just fills and he
do part-time work there.'
So I said, "Who is he?
"Where's he at?
"And he identified me?"
And he said, "Don't look now, Leslie,
"but the man sitting behind
you with the red plaid,
"look like a lumberjack
shirt on, that's the man."
And when he said it, I immediately
turned around and look.
But when I looked back, I
noticed that the white fellow
had a folder, a yellow manila folder open,
and in that folder was my
picture when I was arrested
with my bush and all over my head
because I didn't have my
hair braided or plaited,
and it was all over my
head in the picture.
And I was like, "Well, why?"
I said, "He's showing him picture of me."
So he said, "Leslie," he
said, "just wait here."
He turned around and said
something to the fellow
without knowing it was
the state prosecutor.
And they up and stepped to the side
and was talking and stuff.
Then the state prosecutor
walked up to the,
I think the clerk's desk and
said something to the clerk,
and then they said, they called the case
of State of Maryland versus Leslie Vass.
So Mr. Clarence and Willie Adams
asked to speak to my attorney, Mr. Conrad,
he told them that he couldn't talk to them
because they were listed
as state witnesses
and it would be illegal to talk to them.
I don't know the procedure.
I only thing I could go by what I remember
of this case, I didn't find out
or know anything about the procedures
of criminal law until after
I was convicted and in prison
for 20-year sentence at the age of 17.
This man, the victim,
they told, when they
called my case, they said,
"Leslie Vass, the State of
Maryland versus Leslie Vass.
"Mr. Vass come up to the defense table."
And then the lawyer
started walking up there.
Then the prosecutor said,
"Your honor and we're asking
"that the witness be sequestered,
"the victim be sequestered
from the courtroom."
And he gets up from behind me and walks,
they walked him to the door
and tell him to go
outside and wait outside.
Then they say, "Go sit anywhere
in the courtroom Leslie
"because this is gonna be
identification process."
Now wasn't that dumb?
He was just sitting
behind me you understand?
So why do you need identification process,
when they showed him a
picture and he's sitting
right behind me?
Now you're gonna tell me
to go sit in the courtroom
and then he comes in
and then they asked him,
"Well, did you see the man, the third man?
He ain't say, "Do you see the man?"
They said, "Do you see the
third man that was involved
"in the robbery of you
on November 2nd, 1974?"
And I'm all the while when
they're saying this number,
November 2nd, 1974,
I'm saying, "I was arrested
February 15th, 1975.
"I don't know nothing about no November."
I mean it's like, ever
since I got convicted
of this crime,
I've always had real serious problems
about dealing with how it was done
because I felt like
these people, they were
after being in prison
for as long as I have,
as I was and then finding out the evidence
this things that actually
happened in my case,
all of it boils down to the fact
that the detective that was
in charge of investigating
robbery was aware that the
fellow I was mistaken for
was a informant for them,
and they actually allowed me
to go to prison to protect him.
Yeah, yeah, really.
Judge, when it came time
for us to select a trial,
the lawyer, Mr. Conrad said to me,
"Leslie you suppose, when they asked you
"what kind of trial you have,
"I want you to say court trial."
So I said, "Well, my mother
says I supposed to have a trial
"by jury, what's that?"
He said, "And she also told you to do
"what I tell you to do."
He told me to ask for a trial by court.
And I said, "Well my mother said
"it was it was supposed trial by jury."
He said, "No, I'm telling you
to ask for trial by court.
So when they asked me, I
said, "Okay, trial by jury,"
'cause he said that.
And he said, "Is that what
you want a trial by jury,
"No, trial by court?"
So I said, "Yeah trial by court,"
'cause I was mixed up.
And then he said, "Okay."
They supposedly presented their case,
and this man got on the stand
and started telling about how three men,
he went to make a delivery,
three men approached
him and robbed him $120.
Three men robbed him for $120.
He started explaining how he
left when they robbed him.
He got in the car and left and went
to the gas station and called
the police to report it
because there were no cell phones
and other stuff at the time.
And they met him out there,
the police met him out there
and he explained to him
what happened and all.
Later on that evening,
his coworkers, Mr. Willie Adams
and Clarence McCleary went
with him back out there.
and they observed three men
with whom he identified as the
men who actually robbed him
get into a yellow Volkswagen
with black stripes on it.
Mr. Clarence and them
went to the gas station
to use the phone to call
the police and gave them
the car tag number and the
description of the vehicle.
An all-points bulletin was put out,
the vehicle was stopped and
two men were in the vehicle
admitted committing a robbery,
third man, wasn't in there,
wasn't a third person in there, right.
Based on that information and
his in-court identification
I was found guilty
and I was detained with a $20,000 bail.
That was July 2nd, 1975.
July 18th they brought me back to court
and they sentenced me to
15 years, plus five years
consecutive with the 15
makes it a total of 20 years
for armed robbery.
And I entered into the
Maryland State prison system
the Division of Corrections.
When I went into the
Division of Corrections
I ended up in Maryland Penitentiary
which was a maximum security facility
in the State of Maryland.
- [Mark] So you are no
longer a juvenile now?
- No, I was an adult.
They made me an adult automatically.
Never had a juvenile
waiver hearing anything,
they immediately just processed me
and that's something that I went through
when I was confined, because I started,
I met a guy that was on the tier above me,
which was death row.
And he introduced me to
how to learn the procedures
of doing legal work.
And I ended up, started
studying paralegal,
study paralegal, to sort of,
doing my own work on my own case.
I started obtaining the
documents related to my case,
I received the original
police officer's report
and all that stuff.
In the course of me being confined
I actually became known as an individual
who was learned in law right.
I worked with a lot of individuals,
worked on other individuals cases.
I ended up getting cases overturned,
sentencing reductions and
all that kind of stuff.
And 1980, I actually
learned the name of a guy
that was a real close
friend of those two men
that's supposed to have
been my co-defendants
that I had never met.
And I asked this lawyer whether or not
he would get a photograph of that man
and show it to the victim to see,
whether or not this was the man
I was actually mistaken for?
This man was the person that I ended up
getting a picture of in 1982.
And at the time I had a petition
in federal court 'cause
I got tired of dealing
with the state court 'cause I realized
they wasn't gonna give me anything.
They weren't gonna adhere to the laws
like they supposed to.
Nowhere in the world I was
supposed to be tried as an adult,
and I was a juvenile
without a waiver hearing.
That's not permissible by law period,
but the State of Maryland
kept denying my petition.
So I filed in the federal court
and I got a federal hearing.
The federal court judge
stated that in the decision,
he stated that if I presented
the State of Maryland
with the last contention
about the person I had found out had been,
I had been wrongfully imprisoned for,
if they didn't do anything
and I came back to their court
they would grant me
the relief that I seek.
So two years later, I get a letter
from the Public Defender's Office saying
that my hard work and
perseverance paid off.
The photograph of the
man that I gave them,
their investigators took it to the victim
and he positively identified the man
as being the person who robbed him,
and he even had on the same shirt
that he robbed him in.
I mean, he had the same clothes on, right,
when they committed the robbery he had on,
so he positively identified him.
The state then carried me back to court,
they gave me a court release.
They granted me a court release
from the 20-year sentence.
And when I came home, I then
continue advocating for myself.
I went back and I got a
full unconditional pardon
from the Governor for
the State of Maryland,
I became the first individual
who actually receive a pardon
from the Governor unconditionally
for the time that I'd
been wrongfully convicted.
I then went forth and
filed for compensation
up under a bill, a statute that
the state had at that time,
and they awarded me $250,000
for the 10 years I
spent wrongly in prison.
I have four separate orders
for expungements of the
criminal records of that case.
But when I initially came home,
the first month that I was home
I spoke with a man by
the name of Al Sanders
at WJZ-TV Channel 13 in Baltimore,
and Mr. Sanders remembered
me and remembered my story
as being a basketball player,
he actually set up an interview
for me to play a fellow
that was ranked number,
I think he was ranked number one
in the United States
as a basketball player,
and they had me and him play one-on-one.
I was at the time, I was 28,
I think he might've been maybe 18.
- [Mark] What was his name?
- His name was Len Bias,
and they filmed him and
I playing each other,
and I beat him two games back-to-back.
- [Mark] You beat him twice?
- Twice.
- Len Bias is a number two.
- That's my man.
Yeah, he was number two,
I think he was number two.
- Picked in the draft in '86?
- Yeah.
I didn't follow basketball
when I was locked up
because it took too much out of me,
it reminded me of all
that I was that I lost,
that was taken from me.
But I would take my frustration
and anger out on the basketball court
on every team that we played against.
And we were beating
Virginia State University,
Boise State University,
Hagerstown Community College,
BCCC, every institution or everybody,
every team that they brought in there
we were beating them,
and we was beating them at will.
- [Mark] This was a prison team?
- In the prison team.
But they wasn't writing that up though.
(both chuckles)
They didn't wanna broadcast
how we will beating them.
- [Mark] You are six seven?
- Yeah.
- Six foot seven.
- Yeah, and I had an attitude
that I don't care who thought you was,
they had a guy, now I
forget, he was seven one,
they brought him in there in Hagerstown
and we played against them
and he was talking about
how many points he was gonna score.
I stopped him from scoring
any points, period.
You don't get nothing, this is my house.
After being coming home
and doing the things
that I was doing,
I felt like, I was in a process
of trying to put my life back together.
- [Mark] So your prime years
as a basketball player,
18 to 28 were all spent in prison?
- My children, I started having children,
my first child was born in 1988.
I started working, employed position.
Initially when I would apply for jobs
that criminal record would come up.
Every time, even though
I had expungement orders
a full unconditional pardon and all that,
this criminal record was a burden.
Every time I turned around it came up
and I would contact the State of Maryland,
the Governor, the
Controller, the Treasurer
because these were the
people that I was directly
involved in Maryland
regarding my conviction.
And when I say that, I'm saying,
I didn't talk to the assistant,
I talked to the Governor.
I mean, I went to these
people, they explained to them
that this conviction was burdened me.
I got a bachelor's degree in sociology
from Towson State University.
I was a certified paralegal.
And then I also went back
to school and got 450 hours
of computer office experience
as a computer office specialist.
But I couldn't get a job
as a correctional officer,
I couldn't get a job as a security guard.
I tried to get a job, I left Maryland
and went back to Brooklyn, New York,
tried to get a job working there
for a pharmaceutical company,
and you had to be bonded because you dealt
with different kinds
of medications that was
considered controlled,
dangerous substances.
When I applied for the position,
they couldn't bond me because I had
a criminal record for armed robbery.
Even though I got all
these expungement orders
and documentation, showing
that they had been destroyed,
it was no longer accessible
and all these kinds of things.
But those was just things
that I was being sent,
and the conviction still came up.
- [Mark] How long has this
remained on your record?
- To show you how crazy it is, I was in,
I left Maryland in 2018
and went to Tampa, Florida
to work with an organization
called The Sunny Center
which is a organization
run by a former exoneree
who was on death row,
a lady by the name of Sunny Jacobs.
Her husband actually was the
fellow who was electrocuted
and his body caught on fire
when they did the death
penalty against him.
While there, I went through
things with them about working.
So I left and I applied for a position
in Oxnard, California
for a re-entry program,
and that was done in
2020, which is this year.
I drove from Maryland
to Oxnard, California.
I reached there the
day after thanksgiving.
I stayed there until February the 10th,
when the live scanners or
background check came back
and it had the criminal record on there.
I contacted the State of
Maryland Treasurer's Department
to notify them that
this has happened again.
The last time that it happened
they have paid me an
additional $50,000 in 1998.
The Attorney General Joe Curran
and them sent me a letter
telling me the date had expunged,
they got a separate or
forth expungement order
and that the record would
never come up ever again.
I got a letter from the
administrative judge
for the Circuit Court
saying that this conviction
was removed from the record
and we contacted the FBI Director,
and I was like, "Wow, I ain't got to worry
"about discipline no more,"
here as I'm 62 years old,
and I'm dealing with the
same thing that I was dealing
with back when I was 17.
Man, I lost everything, I
lost, my vehicle broke down
and on my way from leaving
California, when I was told
that this conviction came
up again I lost everything
that I owned, everything.
And it's like I'm starting
over at the age of 62.
- [Mark] What was your
lowest point in all of this?
- The lowest point
really was just recently,
the other day when we was talking.
I got a letter, I hadn't
checked my emails and stuff,
but I had contacted the State of Maryland,
I was trying to make
an agreement with them
so that they could settle this
claim that I have with them,
so that I could actually try
to get get a place to live
and get some of my stuff back and all.
I sent a letter that the agent,
the state agent sent me,
in the letter he's asked,
he's telling me that the conviction
that I'm talking about
that's on the record
had nothing to do with my
wrongful imprisonment case.
And I'm looking at it
and I'm saying to myself,
"I know these people was not
even start doing this man."
I didn't have no criminal
record when I went to prison,
the Governor gave me a full-on
conditional pardon dating
from my arrest in 1975,
which is February 15th, 1975
until I was released August of 1986.
So anything that happened
between that time
of me being incarcerated is
supposed to have been destroyed
because that's what expungement means.
After three years from the date
of the issuance of the
order from the court
they supposed to destroy
all reference to that case.
This is 2020,
what am I counting wrong
or something? (chuckles)
I meant, not trying to
be funny, but honestly.
And to, you know, the
thing about it is that
I'm living, right now,
temporarily in quarters
with my nephew teenager, a kid.
I mean, I was a teenager.
I remember when I was a teenager.
I was set in my ways.
I had my own home,
I had my own business going,
I worked for the child support enforcement
as a fiscal auditor.
I worked for the State of Maryland
as employment placement specialist.
I worked for the Public Defender's Office
as a paralegal intake specialist.
All my documentation
showed that my positions
I worked at all of substance, you know.
And now you're gonna treat me as though
I have no understanding of what's going on
because you don't wanna recognize the fact
that I know what I'm doing as a paralegal.
But mind you, it still
doesn't change the fact,
I was wrongfully imprisoned.
I wasn't one that committed the crime,
so why should I continue to live
and bear the burden of what was actually
a criminal record that
should never have been.
And then you tell people
that it's been expunged
and you can try to give the impression
that you did what you did to
assist me and you never did.
All you did was do things
that was hindrance to me.
The part that hurt the
most of all about this
is that in 2004, while working for the
Department of Labor,
Licensing and Regulation
I had custody of four children.
I was working, I was part
owner to a bail bond business
at that time, and was accused
of a crime that I knew nothing
about just like the same
thing with that first one.
And they held me without bail
based on the same criminal records
that the state in 1998
gave me $50,000 for.
And I purchased the
transcript of the trial
because I couldn't believe
what was being done.
And it was being done blatantly
with disregard for my rights whatsoever.
It was something that I go
through, I really go through.
- [Mark] So what was the second?
- I was found not guilty of everything,
but my kids was, my daughter,
Alicia was 12,
Andrea was 11,
my son was Diamante was seven,
and my youngest daughter Aleija was four.
And they put them in foster care,
and they held them in foster care
for that whole period of time
while I was confined,
waiting to go to trial.
- [Mark] What were you accused of?
- Because I was accused of
being involved in a stabbing
that I had nothing to do
with and no knowledge of.
I went to trial for three days.
The judge that they actually got out,
he was retired, he had retired,
they went in and got him
out of retirement.
His name was Judge Roger
Brown in Baltimore.
They got him out of retirement
for him to handle my case.
And one of the bench officers,
Judge Brown says to state prosecutor,
"This is the kind of shit
y'all put this man through?
"He should sue, you all again."
And I'm saying,
this is a certified copy
of the trial transcript.
I'm not saying paper,
I'm talking about video.
You can see us standing
at there and him talking,
telling the prosecutor that,
"Mr. Vass should sue your ass again."
That's how he said it.
And when I look at that
I think back to it, I said to myself,
"They don't realize the
damage that was done
"when my children, you subject my kids
"to this kind of stuff."
Do they understand that,
right now, my daughter and I,
not Alicia but my other
daughter Andrea and I
are estranged behind that.
Because whatever happened during the time
of her being in foster care
she don't wanna talk about it.
In a way, it's like, I
feel like I'm at fault
for it because of what happened.
And then, you know, I've
try to not allow myself
to stress about it,
but I have to 'cause I'm a parent.
I have grandchildren now that
I focus my life be about.
This that I'm dealing with now
is really hard because it's like
I've worked all the years that I did
to try to reintegrate
myself back in to society
as a positive person.
I've worked with different organizations,
have documentation to show it,
and still the State of Maryland
do not own up to the truth.
You messed up, you messed up,
not once, but several times.
But that mess up has been
devastating to my life,
and I feel that they should
do what they supposed to do.
- [Mark] Were there
moments where you just felt
like this was a dream?
- (chuckles) Yeah, really.
A lot of times I thought,
I couldn't believe
that this was going on, and
that it's still going on.
- [Mark] Did they ever catch the person
that did the robbery?
- Yeah, yeah.
Well, they were not saying
they had to catch him,
they already knew who he was.
They knew who he was.
- He was the informer.
- There was nothing that
they could do to him
because what happened is,
the statute of limitation was 10 years.
Only time that a person can
be charged with anything
is if it was a charge that
was carrying a life sentence,
if it was a rape or murder, right.
They carry life sentences
so there's no statute
of limitation on that.
But I try to, you know,
I would like to ask
Governor Hogan in Maryland,
"What is the statute of limitation
"when you do the things that you do
"to deprive your
constituents of the freedom
"of their life, their livelihood,
"and when the evidence
is presented to you,
"instead you acknowledged
that something has been wrong
"and done wrong, admit it and correct it
"or do whatever you can to correct it."
But that's not how they look at this.
I feel like people don't
understand the gravity
of the things that go on behind this.
It's a lot.
You don't have nothing but
time to stop and think.
I try to stay on my form,
I try to stay on the ball (laughs),
I try to do everything that I can
to not allow me to sit there and reflect
over the things that have been going on.
The things that have been done,
and the things that I've been deprived of
having the opportunity to network
with my children and my
grandkids and stuff like that
because of the circumstances
that I've been dealing with.
And the thing of about it
is that I started out at 17
and I'm 62 now, you know.
- [Mark] Leslie.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- Thank you Mark.
- [Mark] It's an incredible story.
- Thank you, Mark.